je propose qu'on appelle bouder tout de
suite en facetime et dans un instant
aussi on aura stan wawrinka a appelé
west ham wawrinka vainqueur de roland
garros mais qu'on aura au téléphone en
facetime qui va nous donner des
nouvelles de roland garros le voir s'il
est pas trop déçu mon bouder ça va mon
chéri quand on voit ça va ça va depuis
tout à l'heure
écoute moi ça va t'as pas une petite
blague pour nos téléspectateurs pour
univers qui fait là allez vas-y
bon écoute savait qu il était qu un
ouais je sais que toi tu as les blagues
et que c'était j'adore voir avec elle
comme lui il aimerait bien prendre une
guerre pour lui montrer que c'est un
bonhomme comme la veille pas dire le mot
guerre dit il faut donner moi c'est le
premier jour il y à part est 2e jour
pareil troisième jour pareil et le nous
fait le nour abbès parle là c'est bon on
va dire ben ali ouais c'est là c'est
toujours bas d'aller à bercy ne l'entend
pas pareil bonjour mais salut makes
alors il va voir son patron patrick il
faut que tu apprennes à dire le beau
bière entre edward et doit à dire le
molière comme ça quand tu arrives au bar
à bières et prendra pour un bonhomme à
côté alors ils rentrent ils travaillent
bien dans ta bière
il va tirer au clair l'ontario ofa ses
équipes ont joué la donne est moins bon
qu'hier les côtes qui pour bd rotem pas
en bandoulière hôtels ou des hôtels
visionnaire mon frère tu nous rappelles
quand tu veux